la politique c'est en le ca de vos
thèmes de votre sujet de prédilection
mais dans le spectacle vous tapez
désormais beaucoup plus sur la gauche et
même quasiment essentiellement sur la
bouche est il des membres du
gouvernement qui ont eu le courage de
venir vous voir
je cherche apparemment pas beaucoup
dominique strauss kahn mais en tant que
mari d'anne sinclair
ouais tu m'accuses martine aubry non
anti l'abri non je pense qu'elle a un
agenda très chargé
jean pierre chevènement s'est pas dopé
le figurant qui double mr bean
d'habitude qui est la turbine
il viendra peut-être mais mais je vais
je n'ai pas sorti l'opération n'a pas eu
lieu j'avais donc c'est pas lui ai dit
le dos dans l'actualité de ce matin est
ce qu'il y aurait un thème qui pourrait
vous inspirer pour le scar de jeu ce
soir
non mais je regardais barbe lacoste la
corse sais pas je dire un pays c'est pas
un département qui met tout à fait
étranger je sais je le dis parfois pour
rire c'est mon algérie de rechange
bon j'ai même végétation c'est la même
bref ces mêmes aussi un peu le même
tempérament j'aime je m'empresse de dire
que j'aime bien les corses moi je vous
pas globaliser il y à des têtes de cons
parmi les corses mais il ya aussi des
gens très bien et je pense que l'état de
droit et tout ce qu'on veut faire
en corse est bel et bon mais il faut
donner l'exemple
il faut qu'à paris aussi l'état de droit
règne et que certaines affaire soit
réglée sinon les causes comme les jeunes
des cités comme dans d'autres diront
bain qui commence déjà pas régler le
problème du président du conseil
positionnelle ou du président de la
république on parlera des jeunes en tout
cas tout à l'heure l'activité
internationale l'italie est encore sous
le choc de l'acquittement du pilote
américain accusé d'être à l'origine de
la mort d'une vingtaine de personnes
bien tout juste un an
l'avion de ce pilote avait sectionné un
câble de téléphérique dans une station
de ski des alpes italiennes jugé par une
cour martiale américaine
l'aviateur a donc été acquitté philippe
visseyrias embarrassé mais libre
quelques minutes après le verdict
richard ashby est venu dire publiquement
qu'il pensait aux familles des victimes
et qu'il priait pourrait après deux
jours de procès devant le tribunal
militaire de camp lejeune aux états unis
le capitaine des marines richard ashby a
été innocenté le jury a retenu tous les
arguments de la défense pour l'armée
américaine
le drame de caves à l'aise ne serait
qu'un accident si l'avion des marines a
tranché le câble du téléphérique le 3
février 1998 c'est parce que les cartes
aériennes étaient imprécises et parce
que l'altimètre était défectueux
les familles des vingt victimes elles
sont choquées j'ai enterré mon mari il
ya un an
aujourd'hui c'est comme un deuxième
enterrement
1 cave à l'aise et dans les dolomites
italiennes
l'émotion est à son comble ici on avait
longtemps réclamé que le procès des
marines se tiennent en italie pour le
maire du village
l'argument selon lequel les cartes
aériennes étaient imprécises et une
mauvaise excuse
vous savez ces villages qui ont été
survolés à moins de 100 mètres du sol
existaient déjà bien avant la découverte
de l'amérique en visite aux états unis
massimo d'alema le président du conseil
italien s'est dit déconcerté par ce
jugement
il demandera des explications
aujourd'hui à bill clinton entre les
états unis et l'italie
la polémique contient déjà les ferments
d'une crise diplomatique en turquie
preuve de la tension qui existe dans ce
pays depuis l'arrestation du leader
kurde abdullah ocalan
un nouvel attentat a eu lieu aujourd'hui
à une centaine de kilomètres au nord-est
d'ankara trois personnes ont été tuées
et dix autres blessées dont le
gouverneur de la province de coquerie
cet attentat à la voiture piégée
intervient alors que le pkk le parti des
travailleurs du kurdistan vient
d'annoncer une intensification de la
guerre contre la turquie
la sierra leone est un petit pays
d'afrique de l'ouest secouée depuis des
mois par des affrontements sanglants
entre les rebelles et le régime légitime
des affrontements auxquels une force
d'intervention ouest africaine était
censée mettre fin
or d'après un rapport remis à l'onu
cette force d'intervention appelé eco
minc se serait rendu coupable de mauvais
traitements sur des civils y compris des
enfants enfants qui avait été enrôlé de
force par les rebelles qui les avaient
maltraité des enfants qui sont
aujourd'hui pour chasser violemment par
ceux qui devaient donc pacifier le pays
commentaire un de consommer
c'est un ancien hôtel transformé en
centre d'accueil un endroit enfin
presque normal pour ces enfants rescapés
de la guerre
moïse en tee shirt bleu a été enrôlé de
force par les soldats rebelles
difficile d'en savoir plus ils ne
parlent pas ou plus ce qui parle
moïse non ils ne parlent pas ne pas plus
parce qu'il était dans le camp des
rebelles moïse a été arrêté par les
soldats de l'ecomog des nigérians qui
parle comme s'il n'avait pas vu qu'il
s'agissait d'un enfant
moïse n'est pas le seul au cours de
leurs attaques de freetown en janvier
les rebelles ont enrôlé de force 300
enfants qu'ils arrêtent les gens qui
rassemble et nous apprennent à tirer ils
nous font marcher longtemps et nous
apprennent à espionner de la guerre qui
l'a côtoyé de cyprès moïse gardera des
traumatismes difficile à prendre en
charge à freetown
même si aujourd'hui les combats se sont
calmés oui ils semblent traumatisés mais
il n'est pas en bonne santé
nous allons la mener à l'hôpital pour
comprendre ce qu'il n'y a pas de
médecins ici non les meilleurs docteurs
ont quitté le pays depuis longtemps qu à
freetown la chasse aux rebelles se
poursuit la population et fouillés à la
recherche de traces de port d'armes
les enfants n'y échappe privé
d'innocence
ils sont devenus suspects c'est dans un
climat apparemment plus sera que les
ministres de l'agriculture des quinze
ont repris les négociations ce matin sur
la réforme de la pac
si leurs relations sous plus détendue
entre allemands et français il reste
beaucoup d'obstacles à franchir avant
d'aboutir à un compromis sur le budget
agricole
reportage à bruxelles pascal golomer
jean-jacques le garrec
qu'on se le dise le couple
franco-allemand va beaucoup mieux
fini les bouderies et le ministre mta
dialoguer devant les caméras le ton se
détend mais cela ne suffit pas pour
régler tous les problèmes
les projections budgétaires remise au
ministre il hier soir au dîner par le
commissaire européen prouve que le
chemin à parcourir est encore long
ces projections prennent en compte les
demandes spécifiques de chaque pays et
demande qui si elles étaient satisfaites
ferait exploser le budget agricole
prenait part les quinze chefs d'état à
pittsburgh vendredi dernier 260
milliards de francs par an c'est
l'objectif soit sur la période 2000 2006
la somme rondelette de 2000 milliards de
francs le dépassement que prévoit la
commission s'élèverait sur cette même
période
après 263 milliards de francs et la
proposition française de réduire les
aides directes versées aux agriculteurs
de 3 % chaque année ne résoudrait rien
ce n'est pas trois mais 15% de réduction
qui serait nécessaire pour que le budget
de la pac reste dans les limites fixées
bien sûr il ne s'agit que de projections
au cours de la réunion de ce matin
chaque délégation doit en tout cas
rappelé ses priorités mais c'est mardi
seulement que les 15 ministres entreront
dans le détail du budget une belle
querelle de chiffres en perspective
lionel jospin a estimé ce matin qu'en ce
qui concerne la réforme de la pac le
climat est meilleur mais que rien
n'était encore fait le premier ministre
s'exprimait au cours de sa visite du
salon de l'agriculture pour lionel
jospin le comité d'accueil était
beaucoup plus cordiale que pour
dominique monnet qui a été vous le savez
fortement chahuté hier par les
agriculteurs lorrains kim chaque record
lionel jospin a bien failli être en
retard au rendez vous en fait un coup de
fil urgent à donner
oui on en parlera chaussures de d'anouar
veste marron et cravate assortie le
premier ministre avait endossé le
costume du parfait gentleman farmer pour
se rendre au salon à l'heure où jean
glavany défend à bruxelles la position
française sur l'épineuse question de la
réforme de la politique agricole commune
le premier ministre sacrifier nuit au
folklore de la grande ferme parisienne
dévastation qui s'enchaînent les noix de
coco jambon de pays et roquefort
avoir besoin de déjeuner à midi mais
surtout des agriculteurs qu'il faut
rassurer bien effet j'avais jean glavany
juste
avant de rentrer dans celle où j'ai jugé
urgent pour la complice matin lionel
jospin et porter des dernières nouvelles
de bruxelles je pense que la france
n'est pas isolée dans la discussion
agricoles parce que justement elle
défend une politique à mon sens
cohérente
le climat est donc meilleur mais rien
n'est fait donc nous devons être
attentifs et vigilants et et défendre
cette conception de l'agriculture dont
je parlais tout à l'heure
la ronde des hommes politiques va se
poursuivre cet après midi et tout le
week end avec la venue de jacques chirac
dimanche qui refermera cette édition du
salon d'agression
c'est un métier difficile la politique
n'est ce pas guy bedos qui ont entaché
ce lavage sous lionel jospin vivait pas
dans l'irak alors on va passer à
l'actualité sociale noté que le comité
d'entreprise des chantiers navals du
havre n'a pas pu se tenir ce matin
cette réunion qui devait annoncer le
plan de fermeture de l'entreprise a été
reportée par la direction qui a trouvé
l'entrée des chantiers cadenassé par des
manifestants s'opposant aux
licenciements
je vous rappelle que ces chantiers qui
doit fermer en octobre 2000 emploie
actuellement plus de 1100 personnes
et puis les activités dans la mine de
charbon de gardanne devrait reprendre
normalement dans la journée après trois
semaines d'occupation les salariés d'une
société de sous traitance sont parvenus
à un accord avec la direction une amine
cet accord garantit la pérennité de
leurs emplois jusqu'en nous 2000
dossiers de ce genre là alors que claude
allègre vient de présenter les grandes
lignes de ce que devraient être les
lycées français au 21ème siècle
nous avons choisi de nous arrêter sur
deux façons d'appréhender les questions
de violence et de discipline le premier
exemple nous vient de jarny en
meurthe-et-moselle où le principal du
collège a décidé de renvoyer
temporairement chez eux
les élèves de troisième qui n'ont pas
fait leurs devoirs une mesure radicale
qui est apparemment efficace reportage
sur place
jérôme soûlard sylvain gauthier
c'est un collège tout à fait ordinaire
lente et dans la pj de la campagne
lorraine ni incivilités ni violence
particulière juste quelques élèves de
mauvais exemples qui oublie un peu trop
souvent de faire leurs devoirs
celui qui a travaillé et travaillent
celui qui veut pas il travaille pas ça
lui retombe relatifs à la fin d'année
mais c'est tout richard strauss le
principal a pourtant décidé de remettre
un peu d'harmonie dans le travail de ses
élèves
l'avertissement a été envoyé aux
familles dorénavant tout manquement d'un
élève sera sanctionnée par une exclusion
temporaire
la convocation immédiate des parents qui
devront prendre en charge de leurs
enfants
une heure de colle à la maison pour
faire ses devoirs en famille avant de
réintégrer le collège il s'agit surtout
de montrer aux familles quel est leur
rôle elles ont un rôle important à jouer
ou à l'école en face de deux classes
hétérogènes a inventé la pédagogie qui
fait différencier elle a inventé toutes
sortes de dispositifs destinés à venir
en aide aux élèves en difficulté
mais si on n'obtient pas à un moment
donné une démarche de l'élève qui
consiste à comprendre que pour réussir
il faut fournir un travail je crois
qu'on est à côté de l'objectif qu'on
s'est fixé responsabiliser les élèves
mais également les parents
dans l'ensemble ils ont d'ailleurs
plutôt bien accueilli cette nouvelle
mesure
il s'implique dans le travail de leurs
enfants je trouve que c'est bien qu'ils
en plus il ya un phénomène de conseil
les enseignants ou l'équipe éducative
peut les conseiller en leur disant pour
faire comme ci comme ça
et certains parents trouvent que c'est
bien quoi quant aux délégués de classe
de troisième
il souhaite déjà que cette mesure qu'ils
sont les seuls à subir soit étendue aux
autres classes moi je pense que comme
les troisièmes soumis par cette méthode
pourrait que les surclasse aussi parce
que les systèmes 10e d'entrer au collège
ils ont commencé à pas travailler et
cela remettait la méthode tout de suite
ils commenceraient à travailler ils
prendraient pas de mauvaises habitudes
jusqu'en 3e puis à une amélioration de
notre classe qui qui montrent que ça a
bien marché puisqu'il y avait des élèves
qu'ils aiment leur boulot
le fond tout le temps une mesure toute
simple qui respecte les droits des
élèves mais rappelle les règles et les
devoirs élémentaires de la vie d'un
collégien alors le deuxième exemple nous
amène ce matin au lycée professionnel
turgot à roubaix un lycée qui souffrait
il ya quelques années d'une mauvaise
réputation et qui a même failli être
fermée aujourd'hui il est devenu un
établissement au pilote en matière de
lutte contre la violence
le personnel a été renforcée et de
nouvelles méthodes d'encadrement ont été
mises en place un système qui fonctionne
apparemment si bien qu'il pourrait
servir d'exemple et la nuque
alice b tulard première règle arrivé à
l'heure
à 8h15 la grille du lycée professionnel
turgot se referme le retardataire n'est
pas admis en cours
comptez pour absents et toute absence
doit être justifié chaque fois la
famille est prévenu par courrier ou par
téléphone
oui bonjour même pascal thomasse et au
lycée turgot à trouver vous appelle
parce que cédric qui est encore une fois
pas là ce matin première heure à l'appel
il n'était pas l'homme mais l'élève est
aussi invité à la discussion que j'ai
c'est de contacter désormais les élèves
directement que ça pourquoi tu ne viens
pas quelles sont les raisons qui font
que mais c'est de mettre en place
quelque chose où l'élève soit
véritablement at il y a trois ans encore
turbot était le lit c'est le moins coté
de l'académie lanterne rouge pour les
résultats champion pour la violence et
les dégradations
aujourd'hui les bâtiments ont été
rénovés la surveillance renforcée
d'importants moyens ont été affectés
plus d'une centaine d'adultes encadrent
450 élèves presque tous issus de milieux
défavorisés
je dis que pour des jeunes rupture des
jeunes en difficulté au contraire
l'exigence doit être majeur une exigence
une exigence intelligente humaine que
comprise comprise non une exigence
j'allais dire autoritariste écrasante
mais comprise par les jeunes avec qui on
travaille
un principe responsabiliser un moyen le
dialogue une classe refuse certaines
activités en cours le problème est
aussitôt mais au débat entre élèves
professeurs et direction là j'étais un
peu de suivre c'est dommage parce que la
plupart d'entre vous c'est vrai que
comme investi dans certains cas
d'indiscipliné grave c'est la sanction
asean a menacé un professeur est
dégradée des locaux reçue par le
proviseur adjoint il doit maintenant
expliquer sa faute la comprendre puis la
réparer ailleurs hasan aurait été exclu
ici la sanction est négociée est
finalement acceptée
l'élève s'engage
et je n'accepterai pas le choix
georges accepter les propositions sur le
support c'est quoi cette discipline si
je pensais qu'on cdc piège avec une
chance d'être aux primes hassan a
endommagé une classe il viendra
travailler trois heures pendant ses
vacances avec l'ouvrier d'entretien sans
palmes aux élèves de voir notre travail
parce que c'est vrai quand nous on fait
les classes qu'on nettoie ne sont pas là
donc ils savent pas c'est toujours
propos un don classe a permis à obama de
voir ce que c'est nettoyer une salle
quand les tuiles sur les tables en cours
les effectifs sont limités à 24 élèves
si besoin la classe et des doublés ou
alors l'enseignement et renforcer dans
certains cas une aide éducatrice épaules
le professeur et les élèves ça nous aide
comme ça et de la prof
parce que avoir 24 élèves dans une
classe et avoir tous les chats et même
temps pose la question tant sa vache en
boule dans un côté alors que d'avoir eu
une éducatrice
ça nous faisait notre force contrôlé par
les danses éléments personnalisés et
différenciés parce que bon les élèves
ont des niveaux tout à fait différent on
explique différemment pour chacun des
élèves
des méthodes qui portent leurs fruits
aujourd'hui le taux de réussite aux
examens augmente à turgot la violence
est maîtrisé
l'absentéisme a été ramené à un niveau
raisonnable mieux encore la réputation
du lycée est en train de changer
dans certaines filières il y aujourd'hui
plus de demandes d'inscription qu'il n'y
a de places disponibles
l'équipe est aussi falloir vous êtes
vous même allé à la rencontre de ce
qu'on appelle les jeunes en difficulté
dans ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui de
l'es6 testé il ya quelques années à
vaulx en velin que vous inspire d
expérience comme ça que nous allons
devoir présenter
voilà c'est très encourageant ça casse
justement cette sorte de tictacs entre
prévention d'un côté et répressions de
l'autre
ceux qui sont pour la prévention passion
pour des orgies dit qu'est ce qu'ils
sont pour l'impression passe pour les
flics cogneur je crois que il faut
retrouver une relation humaine avec les
soirs les parents responsabiliser comme
certains politiques le disent
responsabiliser les parents quelques
fois de façon radicale oui mais c'est à
dire que et il faut au mieux et je vous
avais les parents mais mais mais il ya
aussi des parents qui sont dans des
situations vous le savez bien
épouvantable perd pas de boulot mère
elle fait ce qu'elle peut pour nourrir
ses hommes ma vie mais aussi donc
évidemment si si le mot m'a jamais vu
son père a travaillé effectivement quand
on lui dit d'aller à l'école
mais en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est
que l'erreur à ne pas commettre c'est de
tomber encore une fois soit dans le
gnangnan tisme soit dans dans une sorte
de folie répressive
ce ne sont pas des délinquants
ontologique et tout ce qui a été dit là
dessus ce qui est montré là ça prouve
que quand il ya un dialogue donc il ya
une sorte de prise en compte de
l'individu sont et c'est pas des
délinquants dans le ventre de leur mère
moi j'ai eu affaire à des types qui
était juge s'était pas d c'était pas des
enfants de choeur et il y avait des
coups de gueule et un vin mais c'était
faux viable parce que j'ai un respect
mutuel s'instaure guy bedos vous restez
avec nous on va parler de votre
spectacle dont quelque 500 toute
l'actualité politique sportive politique
c'est fini maintenant on va parler de
rugby puisque vainqueur de deux grands
chelems consécutifs le quinze de france
mettra demain sa réputation en jeu face
au pays de galles l'équipe de france
pourra en tout cas compter sur la star
la star montante du rugby français il
s'agit de thomas castaignède après
plusieurs blessures le joueur est revenu
aujourd'hui à son meilleur niveau
portrait de ce sportif aux multiples
talents portraits signés denis guérin
emmanuel bach
les enfants ne s'y trompe plus ils ont
fait leurs joueurs préférés à 24 ans
thomas castaignède a déjà tout gagné le
grand chelem avec l'équipe de france
mais aussi une coupe d'europe et quatre
titres de champion de france avec le
stade toulousain
à l'époque le jeune thomas ne s'est pas
encore teint les cheveux en blond mais
tous déjà réussi à cet ingénieur qui
trouve encore le temps de monter sur les
planches ou de recevoir cette semaine le
trophée midi olympique du meilleur
joueur de l'année
le garçon pourtant ne joue pas vraiment
les vedettes j'aime pas trop tirer que
son bon ou en mauvais sortir un individu
d'un groupe
le rugby représente tellement l'esprit
d'équipé esprit de deux groupes que
tirer en un homme du lot c'est assez
difficile pour sortir un joueur du lot
c'est parfois inévitables castaignède
est bien placé pour le savoir france
angleterre il y a trois ans son drop
donne la victoire aux quinze tricolore à
deux minutes de la fin
même scénario il ya un mois en irlande
la france est menée au score mais
castagne elle ne tremble pas et réussit
la pénalité qu'il ne faut pas manquer
savez quand on est buteur il faut être
très fort mentalement si on n'est pas
fort mentalement quand on est buteur
s'est séparé but facile qu'il faut
mettre ses débuts difficiles et thomas
il a il a cette capacité là c'est de
mettre les buts difficile le demi
d'ouverture français n'est pas seulement
buteur plus que d'autres il incarne le
jeu à la française fait d'improvisation
et de prise de risque
l'an dernier par ses coups d'oeil et ses
coups de reins il fut à l'origine de la
démonstration française à wembley face
aux gallois 51 à 0 castaignède
l'alliance du talon et du culot
dans la vie je me pose pas trop de
questions je fonctionne à l'intuition et
et à l'envi ainsi va thomas castaignède
petit génie du rugby français qui
voudraient bien s'offrir un nouveau
grand chelem
en attendant l'automne prochain et la
coupe du monde la nouvelle à présent de
la course à la voile autour du monde en
solitaire avec escales l'italien soldini
qui avait secoué la française autissier
a été gratifié d'une bonification de 24
heures quant à marc thiercelin il attend
l'arrivée dans les prochaines heures
d'un matou 9 pour remplacer celui qu'il
a avait cassé il ya quelques jours nous
venons de recevoir les premières images
du bateau de tirs selon des images qui
permettent de comprendre la semaine que
vient de vivre le navigateur français
alexandre kara un peu comme un bateau
fantôme c'est le navire de marc
thiercelin qui émerge du brouillard de
l'atlantique sud c'était un dimanche le
dernier jour de février sous gréement de
fortune une voilure bricoler sur un mât
brisé le solitaire malchanceux découvre
à l'horizon la silhouette des malouines
quatre jours auparavant il était alors
en tête de la troisième étape
marc thiercelin est victime d'un
démâtage après avoir colmaté une voie
d'eau il décide de rejoindre par ses
propres moyens pour stanley sur les îles
malouines pour réparer et continuer la
course
un port stanley son équipe technique
l'accueil il est temps de constater les
dégâts par chance le solitaire n'est pas
blessé le trou de chance j'étais juste
un mètre et il a traversé les gouttes
pour reprendre la mer le monocoque a
besoin d'un nouveau mât fabriqué en
urgence celui ci a quitté londres hier
soir par avion
il devrait arriver dans l'après midi à
port stanley la réparation effectuée il
faudra dire cela encore quatre jours de
mer avant d'atteindre punta del este et
le terme de l'étape
si mathématiquement le français déjà
perdu à brandon voilà un marin dont la
volonté peut forcer le respect en effet
sentir seul 1
la course en classe 1 serait déjà fini
faute de concurrents puis nous
retrouvons notre habilité
guy bedos qui jouent actuellement les
prolongations en théâtre de la
renaissance à paris
alors qui peut aussi vous aimez bien
jouer avec votre public c'est pour cela
que nous avons choisi de donner la
parole aux spectateurs qui viennent vous
voir vous allez constater si vous ne le
saviez pas déjà que votre pluie qui est
extrêmement divers je ne vous en dis pas
plus facile et rock
les réactions recueillies par
marie-josée jouer et blaise grenier à la
sortie de votre spectacle vous le
trouver mais encore très bien
et encore toujours très bien je vais 12
joue les prolongations son public aussi
éclectique comme des sujets qu'il aborde
tout le monde en prend pour son grade
je reste je l'adoré depuis que je le
suis depuis une trentaine d'années
trente ans que j'entends ça
humoriste j'aime bien et sommes encore
plus qu'il appelle au niveau des sans
papiers il a parrainé c'est important
avec l'un de mes filleuls front collé
brave type qui survit ici comme il peut
ni voleur onidi leur nid tueurs non car
leurs voiliers quart d'heure bon quart
d'heure allait d'ailleurs profité pour
le saboter aux blacks à la maison double
à lui assez sexy ça qu'il a quelque
chose possible et règles je laime je
n'avais que pour les femmes mais comme
beaucoup d'adolescents de ma génération
je suis d'abord énormément masturber
des hectolitres de [ __ ] improductifs
qui sont déversées dans les
canalisations de l'habitation familiale
je trouve très méchant donc j'aime bien
ce qu'il dit c'est un des rares pays qui
balancent des vérités un peu sur tout le
monde avance et un peu plus sur la
gauche maintenant c'est sûr la gauche
sur la droite surtout le moment c'est
génial si vous voulez que je vous dis
sur la droite
à part réclamé une minute de silence
l'artiste c'est la mairie de paris
c'est la mairie de paris ils ont tous
taper dans la caisse il écrit je vous
dise il pourra pas se cacher ils
entendaient ranaldo tiberi forcément
grand couillon
il dépasse en boîte nuit nos décideurs
jugé liste de pleurer sur le malheur des
algériens et des algériennes en algérie
tout en continuant de fournir un coup
d'expulsion quotidienne de la viande
fraîche au couteau des égorgeurs chien
que j'aime bien ça combien de l'os c'est
le siècle où je vais décédé
si ça se trouve
ça ça m'agace la seule chose simbozel
c'est qu'on va tous y passer comment
vous avez trouvé guy bedos pour mieux
faire toujours si vous aviez un message
à lui faire passer
accroche-toi accroche-toi message de guy
bedos ont l'impression que c'est une
question qui vous obsède la durée de
votre carrière vous dites 30 ans déjà 30
ans je rajoute un peu c'est un jeu c'est
un jeu c'est un jeu cdec en fait je sens
que pour beaucoup je m'incruste depuis
trop longtemps la le 10 mai afrique et
ce qui l'a pas mourir si la haye est
toujours là il est à peu près en forme
et énervant et donc il ya eu des
tentatives certaines vos confrères de la
presse écrite de me has been et si j'ose
dire sans succès par vous les égratigner
pas mal dans votre peau
oui moi je me place arty picard c'est à
dire que je me sens un tout petit peu
journalistes alors ben je donne mon avis
sur les choses et certains pensent parmi
vos confrères que c'est chasse gardée et
que un saltimbanque comme moi ne doit
pas s'aventurer sur leurs terres mais
ben je continue à le faire quand même
qu'ils peuvent êtres humains quand vous
ne parlez pas sur scène de politique ou
d'évolution de la société comme vous
l'avez fait avec nous vous évoquez
beaucoup le sexe est ce que vous ne
seriez pas obsédé situé quai c'est une
réponse non je peux vraiment excédés je
suis suis atterré s'est intéressée par
ces choses oui oui
non ça reste que ça reste une des
valeurs sûres finalement dans le maine
où tout fout le camp
l'amour l'amour avec un grand a et qui
sont pas oubliés mais si c'était
compagne et du plaisir de la séduction
on citera c'est pas mal ça compte aussi
je suis d'accord mais vous avez des
fiches sur sanne je sais que vous
n'aimez pas cette question est ce que
vous attendez un peu dommage ou pas
franchement durant toute la soirée je me
suis demandée at-il son style cascade
sur bayonne
non il ya vraiment des textes écrits et
joués ce que j -cd si jamais des fiches
blanche
ça serait le mime marceau jouer quand
même peur de trous de mémoire mais ne
mangeait des textes écrits mais je les
jeux les bouscule un peu ce texte mais
ça me serve d'antisèches oui ça parce
que j'ai beau que j'abhorre beaucoup de
sujets et puis quelques fois je suis
obligé de glisser des sujets qui
évoluent et donc il vaut mieux que j'ai
ça puis et puis c'est devenu maintenant
c'est à la partie du spectacle joué avec
j'ai une question concernant le
spectacle il n'ya pas d'empreintes ou
tout au moins il ya un entracte un petit
peu particulier ce faire vous obligé des
gens restés sur place mais je vous
assure que c'est bien reçu sa ba par
aman oui il réagira pas eu de plainte
personne n'est parti on arrose le bar et
puis se marre non mais j'ai en fait
cessé biologique
ça m'a été imposé pendant mon grand âge
est bon parce que je me livre à une
prestation encore et graphique qui oui
qui a l'air de plaire mais qui met sous
les 20 secondes tiffin et donc je ne
pouvais pas enchaîner directement
je suis allé chercher une chaise et puis
j'essaie de faire un tract je reste
presqu'une demi-heure face au public où
je papote comme ça sur les sur les
bruits l'effet du joug de la semaine bon
et bien reste avec nomao proposer une
fin de journal animal pour ne pas dire
bestial dans un instant nous irons en
angleterre découvrir que là bas on prend
des assurances pour protéger des poules
mais tout de suite un reportage sur
l'élevage en france des mulets c'est
très sérieux reportage chez un dresseur
avec jean yves perrin vincent maillard
un peu hésitante ce sont ses premiers
pas dans le vignoble de banyuls cinq
jours seulement que
mul de quatre ans la bourse est jeune
fille un peu hésitant vincent son guide
à rêver de ses labours des nuits
entières retrouver les gestes qu'on a
pris les frères parce s est associé
c'est aimer aussi il avait une mule
jusqu'en 84 il travaillait avec elle ils
ont approuvé l'envi de vincent
l'histoire d'un funambule à banyuls et à
la fois pour renouer avec une vieille
tradition gérait pour préparer l'avenir
dans le sens où c'est une belle
alternative aux aux techniques chimiques
de désherbage et puis c'est vrai que sur
bagnols ça correspond à une réalité
parce que on a quelques difficultés à
faire passer des engins qui roule sa
mule
il l'a trouvée ici dans l'ariège chez
olivier courtiade le dernier dresseur de
mulet qui exercent en france
ce jour-là il débours est à mu les
désobéissants pour le compte d'un
particulier
il a un mois et demi pour lui faire le
caractère 25 ans de métier ça aiguise le
coup d'oeil là c'était la première fois
qu'il avait un mort et des guides donc
assouplissement de la bouche de la nuque
et latérale à prendre 5 e hve les
chevaux sont beaucoup plus craintifs et
moins intelligent il assimile moins vite
et plus compter sur tout autre vie une
tête de mule ça veut dire que c'est un
animal intelligent et les hommes
n'aiment pas les étrangers dit gens ce
qu'ils peuvent pas les soumettre passé
bien des voix il cède l'aï celle de plus
en plus et ça c'est bien et puis il y
les sur trois pieds ça veut dire qu'il
est au repos ça ça me plaît comme c'est
une image son mot il est détendu c'est
bien puis c'est que c'est fini l' idée
est parfaitement calme au monde c'est
bon tu as le et c'est bon à l'époque
olivier n'a jamais eu de tracteur quand
il a hérité de sa ferme de 20 hectares
moitié auprès moitié en forêt il a
choisi limiter les investissements un
sou de gagner c'est aussi un sou qu'on
n'a pas dépensé at il l'habitude de dire
sa méthode pour dresser les animaux les
faire participer à tous les travaux de
la ferme
charrier le fumier deux fois par jour
labourer les quelques parcelles
cultivables et bardé les fûts de sapin a
battu par la dernière neige il ya de
quoi faire
de quoi faire voir aussi à ses
stagiaires
ce tour c'est qu'elle n'est pas un
intérieur dans les chaînes mais les
revenus sont modestes
il vit de la vente des animaux qu'ils
dressent des mulets mais aussi quelques
beaux ses clients des particuliers des
metteurs en scène de cinéma qui ont
besoin d'être l'âge est de plus en plus
d'agriculteurs les passer en temps où
les seuls animaux que je dressais
servait aux loisirs uniquement et
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que que ce
soit pour le débardage en forêt ou que
ça soit pour l'agriculture l'agriculture
biologique en particulier j'ai des
demandes de plus en plus nombreuses qui
sont qui sont doubles parce qu'en fait
il faut fournir et l'animal qui convient
et la formation pour le pilote parce que
c'est pas évident surtout quand on sort
d'un milieu urbain et même quand on est
un agriculteur d'un certain âge
c'est-à-dire jeune qui n'a pas vécu les
abîmant de trait c'est pas du tout
évident de se remettre de devenir
animalier cette action car vivre avec
des animaux oiseaux meurent leur parler
les soigner cela s'apprend
une tâche quotidienne quelquefois
fastidieuse que certains acheteurs
oublie régulièrement
il faut leur rappeler
olivier le sait bien lui qui vit avec
eux toute l'année bompas à présent des
mules aux poules une poule britannique
illustre bien l'immense passion que les
anglais vous aux animaux le propriétaire
d'un pub à assurer pour 20000 francs une
poule qu'il considère comme sa fille ce
n'est pas une plaisanterie l'histoire
est vraie elle nous est racontée par
etienne leenhardt
maurice chevalier aurait plus dédié sa
chanson à violette la plus célèbre des
poules d'angleterre depuis que son
propriétaire un patron de pommes de
l'essex a dépensé 20 mille francs pour
assurer son piper le contrat précise
qu'il touchera 10 millions de francs en
cas de vol
alors gros coup de pub ou coup de coeur
violette fait désormais partie de notre
famille et je prie le ciel bourg qui ne
lui arrive rien cette aide est précieuse
pour nous elle n'a pas de cris des
histoires comme celles-là l'actualité
britannique en regorge du chien habits
récompensé pour avoir perdu 25 kilos en
quelques semaines au charme fou et
locataires des gouttières du 10 downing
street la résidence du premier ministre
et dont la disparition avait entraîné
une très violente campagne de presse en
passant par la cavalcade effrénée de
deux cochons promise à l'abattoir et qui
avait tenu en haleine tout le pays
pendant une semaine en grande bretagne
les animaux sont des stars et on les
traite comme c'est un enlèvement est
toujours possible car violette comme
d'autres animaux est aujourd'hui devenu
une star
elle est donc assurée contre l'
enlèvement et nos conditions d'assurance
sont très précises stoppé au bout d'chou
mais comme toutes les stars ils ont
aussi leurs humeurs fernand le faisan
vient lui de faire les gros titres
parce qu'on l'a surpris vidéo amateur à
l'appui en train de harceler le facteur
du village obligé à plusieurs reprises
de battre en retraite
aux dernières nouvelles le courrier
n'est plus distribué le village est en
colère et aucune assurance ne couvre les
facteurs contre les agressions de
faisans et autres gallinacés
ça vaut bien la vache à jospin moi
j'adore les animaux mais il faut pas que
ça devienne pathologique non plus
ça vous afflige la wii j'ai nommé parce
que comment dire on peut émerger deux
chats de chiens ils sont je crois très
bien traités ils sont beaucoup de place
dans la maison mais ne devrait pas
assurés non
et puis il n'ya pas une canonisation des
animaux c'est quand même ça prouve un
dérapage mental assez de choix
guy bedos merci d'être resté en notre
compagnie vole en silence les signaux
naturels que vous êtes au théâtre de la
renaissance jusqu'au 10 avril
merci beaucoup ça nous a fait plaisir
merci on termine par un mot de la bourse
de paris le cac